Let's go to let's go to Bobby
from Jersey, Bobby from Jersey.
You're on the air. Hey, David, do you hear me?
I do. You're kind of coming through metalic.
Is now better? Yes, it is OK.
Do you think social media has polarized discourse?
Relatively everything, especially politics?
Yes, I would say so.
If so, what do you think
is a better solution, is a better solution for
the highest and keep the polarization at bay?
Well, I think that what you have to do is you have
to consider that it's sort of like when people say
if it weren't for the Internet, you wouldn't
have identified some identity theft scams,
you wouldn't have cyber bullying. You know, they
list all the bad things. But most of us I mean,
pretty much everybody I've met still believes
that the Internet has done more good than harm. So
it's a net benefit. I think it's similar. I
mean, social media has allowed it's allowed the
democratization of news reporting. It's allowed
all sorts of different people to connect and to
establish relationships. It's allowed independent
media to grow and the creation of all sorts of
businesses. And it's also done lots of terrible
things. I still think that it's a net benefit.
And I think that that's what we have to keep in
mind. It's sort of like, you know, go back to
agriculture. Agriculture is what first allowed
the development of technology because you had
only some people working on food production,
freeing others up to do things like philosophy
and building and whatever. But it also brought
diseases that come from crowding and, you know,
all these different things. But I think
most people would agree there's been a net
benefit from agriculture. I think you have
to see things sort of at the macro level.
Yes, but do you think there's certain regulations,
social media companies or maybe people on social
media should have to obey too many? Like, I don't
know how your opinion on the platforming or.
I'm unclear. I'm unclear that this is something
that would be fixed by by regulation. I'm not
sure about that. I think we need a big picture
regulatory infrastructure around the Internet,
which includes net neutrality. But as
far as the individual social network,
I'm just I think that the solution
really is education and media literacy.
I was about to say that like media
literacy classes, psychology classes and
things of that nature, that may say that's
my view of how people behave better.
Yeah, I don't know that. I don't I don't
I think you need a regulatory framework,
but I don't know that you legislate
your way out of polarization.
OK, I just want to hear your opinion on that one.
I'm glad to give it. Thank you. Let's take a quick
break. But if you're holding, don't
hang up unless you're mad and want to
hang up. But I'm going to continue taking
calls right after this very short break.